how's the Cobras my name is Pam I am a
little sick supporting me if I'm not to
it in this video today we're going to do
another couple games from Full Sail
University for those who don't know Full
Sail offer great programs from animation
to game development they have a campus
which is equipped with professional
games studios and labs I don't know what
that means but it sounds cool where you
get to create a game from start to
finish that's like my dream if I wasn't
sitting here they also offer degrees
online so what are you waiting for it's
me from the future I've come to tell you
because I forgot to say that these games
were developed by full se graduates and
if you want to check out any of these
games they're all linked in the
description alright let's get to it
first game we're gonna play is Dungy
advanced how badass
does that look okay I get to name myself
well ok which one should I look like
this one looks like the dumbest one
[Music]
while the walking animation is the best
thing I've seen in my entire life
okay well that dementia never mind never
mind adventure let's go back okay so I
keys spells over
oh [ __ ] look at that [ __ ] [ __ ] look
at look at you see that candle oh I like
the retro feel let's go to the first
onion I'm wrecking a bunch of pots which
is always a good sign but I'll be on my
way now to you buddy tap down oh god you
guys I got oh god it's got chill chill
chill I'm trapped
tonight no no no this can't be happening
Adventure adventure awaits there's
something satisfying about the clicking
mat [ __ ] you let's rock it Rick slob of
slime look at that [ __ ] 369 [ __ ]
nice shooting back oh god oh god this
looks really really bad you know I'm
gonna - look at that [ __ ] am i poison
[Music]
come on man
oh there is that's my man that thing
looks scary nevermind I wrecked that
[ __ ] oh god I'm gonna be honest I
actually didn't think I would enjoy this
game but it sucks I [ __ ] love myself
a good dungeon crawler after you know
what I mean ladies this could be the end
of Pierce
oh my god this is definitely the end of
pins how the [ __ ] do I get out of this
situation okay you know what we're just
gonna fight it out sometimes you just
have to [ __ ] man up I have four
[ __ ] health what do I know we're
doing so well if I had actual time to
play games that's the kind of game I
would love to spend time with let's move
on to the second game so the next game
is also made by a team from the full
sales
let's go lost marbles I can't relate to
that let's do it I'm a ball Oh God
nice look at dad
the durable secured his little Paul I
ever seen of a life okay man look at
them nuts go dammit [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh god I got a shortcut there that's
perfect
[Music]
Wow back Bob but everything you know oh
my god this made it a lot more exciting
[ __ ] yes
[Music]
by dammit that was worse competitive
pair sisters come out or this game any
price
oh my never Eve it all
forty-nine wait someone did this in five
seconds what the [ __ ] how did you do
that
it looks like we have to get it in 20
seconds let's go baby
ball go go go go I'm sweating like a
[ __ ] pool of [ __ ] I don't I don't
know what I'm saying all I want in life
is to be remembered for having a [ __ ]
high score on lost marbles alright is
that too much to [ __ ] ask well then
I'm sorry go go go go go go go go
did I do it did I do it captain nine
eight bar three milliseconds okay here
we go here we go here we go [ __ ] [ __ ]
that yes go go go go go go all right all
right
oh my god we're a [ __ ] medal oh my
god give it that sanic speed I pray to
the sanic God every night give me some
of that sweet sanic bitch-ass go go go
hey number ten top ten baby Babs
[Music]
Oh oh damn it feels good to be a
gangster what are we doing here well
that's just great
all right press I'm sorry but I'm gonna
have to stop myself right there right
man up can I get a get a go what did you
be like mom look I made this game as
wouldn't that be cool well then you
should sign up to Full Sail University
and look hang out with other people who
make games and actually have friends and
[ __ ] how about that that sounds great I
know I'm impressed I thought
Bofur generally fun games so yeah big
thanks to Full Sail for sponsoring this
episode and aspiring game developers
like I said they have great programs for
animation to game development so
definitely check them out in the
description or at Full Sail dot edu
slash PewDiePie and maybe one day I'll
play our game that's it for now I think
we're so much for watching as always
stay awesome brush